a night of technical snafus and a lot of
emotions during America's Got Talent
live shows but the real waterworks came
courtesy of Mel beach I'm kind of
imagine this would be like no B's
wedding nights a lot of ads
[Applause]
anticipation not much promise or
delivery they should know if you say
something inappropriate it's gonna get
like stuff thrown at him you should know
kindly way I make sure there's no ice in
it this time I just hope I would have
had like cranberry juice in there or
something and his whole body would be
really sticky be honest how did that end
did you guys have some words during
commercial commercial break he was there
and you guys know whatever but you have
to understand tonight was a two-hour
show there was a lot of emotions there
was a lot of like stories that you don't
want just focus on somebody's story you
want to focus on their performance but
you can't help but listen to that story
also and root for them Mel had a special
connection with 13 year old singer Evie
Claire whose father is currently
battling stage 4 colon cancer you like a
singing angel and then it made me think
of my dad and I just think your dad's
gonna be proud of you no matter what
when his story came up again I'm like oh
my gosh that's very similar to mine and
I wanted to put the story aside and just
focus on her voice but it all just
collided and she's thank God she has
such a beautiful voice and her story's
just so much like mine so tonight was a
rollercoaster ride
you